un momento que es raro ver y que pronto
podría volverse aún más raro el informe
de wwf afirma que desde 1970 las
poblaciones animales mundiales han
disminuido en más de dos tercios es una
disminución acelerada que hemos estado
monitoreando durante 30 años y continúa
yendo en la dirección equivocada en 2016
documentamos una disminución del 60 por
ciento
ahora tenemos una disminución del 70 por
ciento todo esto pasa en un abrir y
cerrar de ojos en comparación con los
millones de años que muchas especies han
estado viviendo en el planeta el informe
asegura que la humanidad ha impactado el
75% de la tierra libre de hielo del
planeta y el 40% de los océanos del
mundo esto se debe a la sobrepesca y la
expansión agrícola actividades que
invaden los hábitats naturales dejando a
muchos animales con pocos recursos para
sobrevivir un tercio de toda la tierra y
la mayor parte del agua dulce ahora se
destinan a la producción de alimentos lo
que ha provocado un consumo exagerado
las especies disminuyen más rápido en
algunas áreas que en otras
américa latina' tuvo una caída
el 94% en comparación a las cifras en
1970 tenemos que actuar ahora las tasas
de recuperación de la biodiversidad
suelen ser mucho más lentas que las de
la reciente pérdida en la biodiversidad
a medida que los seres humanos siguen
invadiendo los hábitats naturales y
entran cada vez más en contacto con
animales salvajes también aumenta el
riesgo de futuras pandemias